zipper spill you've gotten into trouble
with someone you've talked about on Tick
Tock and who a very very very famous a
plus plus list person if you guessed it
in one guess I'd give it to you called
me to ask me to please remove the post
and apologize to Meghan Markle when I
posted the
Crimea River a personal friend of hers
Oprah Winfrey nope I would have given it
to you though you get one guess I would
have given it to you and you apologized
no I didn't take it down but said you
need to take that down like you need to
yeah delete that post and I said no that
post came just hours ahead of Megan's
sit down with Oprah in 2021 but after
Bethany watched the interview she wrote
emotional distress and racism must feel
suffocating and Powerless I'm sorry if
it hurt or offended you better thoughts
on the famous couple didn't stop there
be a housewife lean in be Infamous
because it's not going that great more
or less have said that she would be the
perfect fit for a housewife
many of Meghan markle's decisions would
be very good for housewives well because
if you're striving for infamy
oh my God they had such a veil over them
they were so perfect looking they've
made some interesting choices it's like
they're feeding off of each other's bad
ideas yeah for how to combat
being raised in a family where you were
not the most relevant where you were
maybe cast aside or thought of as not or
the spare air and an actress that wasn't
really that relevant an actress so she's
got a hard-working amazing career great
you're an actress that's honorable but
they both have probably wanted more out
of their individual lives previously
getting together and they both want to
get theirs and I just think that they're
not wise in how they're going about it
are we going to talk about Megan and
Harry uh super spill who is the last
celebrity to slide into your DMs and
what did they say Prince William slipped
into my DMs last week saying I loved
what I said about Harry and Megan but I
didn't respond honey that is how we get
the tea a stirring over here let's
cheers
okay that didn't actually happen we
think but no one is safe from Bethany's
Tick Tock rants she recently had some
strong words for fellowex housewife Kim
Zolciak and her estranged husband Kroy
Biermann hey I'll show a no-go I hate
fronting and stunting pay bills for
people to be draped in luxury and
diamonds and bragging about all that
they're spending when they don't got it
like that and they're not paying their
bills is enraging and insulting to other
people so that's why I'm talking about
it because Americans need better role
models for who they're watching on
television than people who are lying
cheating and stealing and bragging
Bethany knows a thing or two about
finances her book business is personal
is now available in paperback she's also
got her podcast just be as well as her
YouTube channel if there's just a
freedom and the place and a space to
opine to just rant to have interesting
conversations it's the same thing I'm
doing with my YouTube Right Bethany
series because it's direct to consumer I
have something I want to talk about I
think it's important okay let's do it
it's up two days later right it's really
freeing and don't forget she sold part
of her skinny girl cocktails Empire in
2011 for a reported 100 million dollars
now Bethany's all about her wine Forever
Young Rose I think I did a pretty good
job the first time entering the spirits
industry and it's not an easy business
so I understand the spirits business
it's a very difficult one to break into
particularly as a woman and I've done
that I have good relationships I have a
good reputation and I think we're gonna
nail it
okay super spill ooh
ooh delicious
it's good good stuff Mama any chance
that we could see you in action on
Ultimate girls trip what would it take
to get you there I there's a number I
suppose but I Bravo could not afford the
number it would take for me to go on an
ultimate girls trip yeah what will it
take for you to go back to television
will there ever be a day where we see
where we might see you back on TV I
don't
know what my relationship to television
is we should not be holding our breath
that we'll be seeing you on anytime soon
should not be holding your breath all
right fair enough what was one business
decision that maybe you could read you
or just never would have gotten into
from the get-go I didn't enjoy doing a
talk show just because I don't want to
get dressed up every day and be handled
and have so many people around it's just
not my personality just because it is
something other people would want or
it's hard to get doesn't mean you should
do it one thing Bethany said yes to was
her fiance a movie producer Paul Burnett
the couple has been engaged for two
years who's more likely to be a bride or
groom Zilla you are Paul
oh me
me really yeah when is the wedding we
have not planned a wedding
why don't the hold up that I don't know
that I want a wedding I was married and
I had a really traumatic traumatic
experience so it's probably Associated
to that just that whole chapter of my
life was by far the hardest I've ever
experienced one positive that did come
from her failed marriage to Jason Hoppy
her 13 year old daughter Brynn what's
something you've done recently that
embarrassed friend you're now teenager I
went to her school and she was in band
then a boy who was in a great higher
walked by and he was like he was very
good at his instrument and I said you
did a great job
no no like this was serious this wasn't
even joking she's like no ma do not do
that I'm like what do you mean what do
you mean it's just complimenting
something
[Music]